when Hurricane sandy slammed the East
Coast last fall the frankenstorm blazed
a trail of destruction and even death
here in Red Hook Brooklyn waist high
floods destroyed the ground floor of
practically every building in sight
residents in this public housing project
went without electricity for two weeks
now things are getting even Messier new
york and new jersey poles are demanding
the taxpayers who have never even been
east of the Mississippi River pick up a
hundred percent of cleanup costs
Congress has signed off on nine billion
dollars in sandy-related insurance
payments and will vote on as much as 50
billion dollars more an aide by january
fifteenth the truth of the matter is and
I say this as a resident of earthquake
prone Southern California New York New
Jersey and everywhere else would be
better off without federal funds rushing
to the rescue like a quick fix for a
junkie this money including super
subsidized flood insurance simply allows
a rotten situation to keep on keeping on
consider the effect on New York City's
mass transit system which will get
billions of relief dollars in the wake
of Sandy the tax dollars at God after
the 911 attacks resulted in some of the
biggest boondoggles in recent memory
including a 3.4 billion dollar World
Trade Center transit hub and a 1.4
billion dollar Fulton Street transit
center while we don't yet know the final
language of the 50 billion dollar relief
bill you can bet that it will be poor
cure than a bacon buffet the original
Senate version included 150 million
dollars for Alaskan fisheries funds to
repair the Smithsonian Institution's
roof to fix up the Kennedy Space Center
and to buy brand new vehicles for the
Department of Homeland Security I feel
awful for the businesses and homeowners
here in Red Hook who lost their
livelihoods and savings because of the
storm but many of them didn't have flood
insurance because it was too expensive
if flood insurance is too expensive
maybe people shouldn't live in low-lying
coastal areas now they're poor choices
are being compounded by government once
again illustrating its corruption and
inefficiency that's just one of the many
lessons washed away not by the fury of
Hurricane sandy but by billions in
wasted taxpayer dollars for reason TV
I'm Kennedy
you